wer hat den showdown gewonnen das werden
unsere ringrichter jetzt entscheiden die
bild politikexperten yvonne weiß sind da
jan schäfer und claus strunz einen
wunderschönen guten morgen ihr hattet
eine kurze nacht bei dem ein oder
anderen sieht man ist in den augen schön
dass wir trotzdem so früh aufgestanden
seit klaus wer ist dein gewinner des
abends na ja also wir fangen mal anders
anja also christian lindner hat nicht
gewonnen war aber ziemlich gut muss man
sagen hat gezeigt dass er regierungs
format hat mich hat am meisten
überrascht frau baerbock denn wenn man
mal in die war gestern in einer sehr
sehr guten form bleibt ja auch stehen
und ich habe gestern die ganze zeit
gedacht wie gefährlich die dem
bürgerlichen lager geworden wäre wenn
sie es nicht am anfang mit diesen
plagiats dingen vergeigte dies steht
wirklich für das neue für das frische
kennt sich nicht so mit dem grundgesetz
ausgeschenkt können sie noch üben aber
das war fand ich überzeugend wegen der
frischzellenkur die wir brauchen und für
mich war der eindeutige sieger markus
söder der zwar ein bisschen rum gummelt
hat neben armin laschet aber in jeder
sequenz bei jedem redebeitrag den er
hatte er hat glaube ich jeder im
bürgerlichen lager gedacht wenn der und
der das miteinander machen würden und
nicht der dann wäre die mehrheit ganz
sicher auf dieser seite dann würden wir
da mitgehen ist aber nicht so er macht
es ja und interessant finde ich keiner
der beiden kanzlerkandidaten
die ist wahrscheinlich wirklich werden
keiner der beiden künftigen möglichen
kanzler hat es bei mir aufs podium
geschafft die wirkten müde erschöpft und
sozusagen die ziellinie vor augen
herbeisehnt es wird schon gut werden und
jetzt ist ja die frage der oder der und
mit wem wir sehen wenn die augsburger
puppenkiste
frau weiterhin nicht sein aber es ist ja
die muss raus was war dein highlight
denn die die linden eschen
zwischenrufe also das beste an diesem tv
september siebenkampf war das was man
nur gehört hat zwei zwischenrufe von
lindner
die
richtungsweisend meine meinung wir haben
ja jetzt alle solche ökos sind es ja
schön wenn die nächste bundesregierung
dann auch endlich klimaneutral wird ich
fahre seit sieben wochen im wahlkampf
mit dem bus durch die gegen auch gerne
mal nachts um im inland nicht zu fliegen
mit ihrem wahlkampf busch wichtig das
ist ja keine erhaltungs frage sondern es
steht klar im grundgesetz was aufgabe
von staatlichkeit ist und es auch im
grund gerecht auch ein letztes mittel
auch sie jetzt auch staatsrechtlers
steht doch nicht drin so ein
wohnungswechsel dass ein letztes mittel
auch am start zur verfügung steht ist
sie jetzt auch staatsrechtlern hatte und
der wahlkampf bus das muss man sich ja
vorstellen fährt ja mit dem bus nicht
etwa mit einem elektroauto durch die
gegend also mit einem wahlkampf bus das
als vorteil zu bezeichnende schon kühn
hat lindner erkannt und gleich attacke
und das zweite die staatsrechtler in
bezieht sich auf dieses völkerrechts
thema werbung hat ja häufiger darauf
hingewiesen dass die völkerrechtlerin
sei hier hat sich mit der enteignung
irgendwie ein bisschen vergaloppiert da
hat lindner auch gleich den punkt
gemacht und politisch spannend ist das
weil die beiden ja womöglich miteinander
eine koalition machen werden nämlich in
einer möglichen ampel haben wir nach
vorne gesehen ja also klaus ich bin ein
bisschen anderer meinung insgesamt
glaube ich war das gestern er nicht yes
we can das war eher yes we can also es
war wirklich extrem
langweilig fand ich die kandidaten waren
müde also wenn das ein ausblick ist auf
die nächste auf die nächsten vier jahre
dann
glaube ich würde es eher bitter für
deutschland also man hat den kandidaten
angemerkt der wahlkampf sitzt ihnen noch
in den knochen deswegen mein erster
platz bleibt leer also niemand hat da
habe ich so verformt dass man sagen
würde war das ist jetzt der geborene
kanzler für die nächsten vier jahre auf
platz zwei setzte ich christian lindner
der dann doch klaus hat gerade eben auch
schon erwähnt aber wenigstens
angriffslustig war den frischesten
eindruck aller kandidaten machte und auf
platz drei würde ich markus söder setzen
das reicht erst mal fertig machen vielen
dank der ebenfalls sehr angriffslustig
wirkte wirkte einerseits müde aber
angriffslustig und was beide auszeichnet
sie haben etwas was armin laschet
beispielsweise gestern auch wieder
überhaupt nicht rübergebracht hat olaf
scholz auch nicht präzise auf den punkt
formuliert also dass der zuschauer auch
wenigstens mitnehmen konnte wofür steht
christian lindner wofür steht markus
söder zwei politiker die zuspitzen
können aber auch klar sagen können was
ihre positionen sind das war bei den
anderen zum teil sehr sehr schwierig zu
verstehen was war dein highlight welches
hast du ausgepackt highlight ist schwer
weil ich fand es war insgesamt eher eine
zumutung für die zuschauer aber es gab
einen moment von olaf scholz vielleicht
hören wir uns denen einmal kurz an
ich könnte jetzt sagen auch
wahrheitsgemäß und richtig ich kaufe
gerne regionale lebensmittel ein das ist
ein beitrag dazu aber ich finde es
gehört auch zur ehrlichkeit dazu dass
man als ein politiker der mit
sicherheits geschützten fahrzeugen
unterwegs ist mit vielen flugzeugen
fliegt nicht den eindruck erweckt als
sei man der beste beim reduzieren des
co2 abdruck das ist etwas das ich als
zynisch empfinden würde ich finde
wahrheit hilft hier auch wenn ich mit
dem fahrrad ins ministerium fahrer wird
sich drei oder vier mal gemacht habe
dann sind auch noch viele andere dabei
und das ist keine verbesserung der
klimasituation ist gut für mich und
deshalb finde ich muss man da ehrlich
sein damit da kein falscher eindruck
entsteht ja unglaublich ehrlich zum
thema klimaschutz sehr ehrlich aber es
zeigt auch das ganze dilemma in dem wir
uns befinden denn es gibt nicht nur olaf
scholz der bundesminister ist und bka
beamte als sicherheit hat es gibt viele
andere menschen die ihn auch in
lebenssituationen sind in denen sie
möglicherweise nicht so gut
beispielsweise auf ihren co2 ausstoß
verringern können das heißt olaf scholz
spricht hier etwas an auf seiner
position dass viele viele andere
bürgerinnen und bürger ähnlich empfinden
und ich darf in dem dilemma befinden wir
uns ist gut dass es mal so gesagt wurde
aber es zeigt in gewisser weise auch die
verlogenheit der klimapolitik ich finde
es interessant dass keiner von euch
bisher christian lindner auf platz eins
gestellt hat es war ja zum ersten mal
die gelegenheit dass er mit den
spitzenkandidaten also mit den
kanzlerkandidaten sich sozusagen messen
konnte darauf haben wir ja alle gewartet
man sagen also steht in dem fall niemand
vor ihm also ist der jetzt bei mir ich
bin gespannt wer hat für mich die beste
figur gemacht ja ich verstehe das jetzt
mal wörtlich und beziehe das auf die
körperliche präsenz und dann ist bei mir
die nummer eins olaf scholz immer wenn
ich ihm zuhören oder ihn beobachte dann
habe ich im hinterkopf das lied ice ice
baby
ich weiß nicht ob er das kind
doch wenn das ist ein super lied ich
hätte
jetzt kennt natürlich kennt ja jeder
genau und ich finde
du musst mir so retten
unser ziel ist es
als hanseat also ein hanseat an sich ist
schon recht bald schon will darin aber
scholz kann immer noch eins draufsetzen
es ist windig niemand wird so
ausgeglichen und so ruhig und so über
den dingen schwebend wie er das liegt
daran dass er jeden tag acht kilometer
joggt und ich muss sagen
repariert dadurch auch jeden angriff war
extrem faktensicher ist er hatte alle
zahlen zum wohnungsbau zum beispiel
parat und ich muss sagen scholz könnte
eigentlich dadurch und sich gerade gar
nicht
ich und scholz wir gehen jetzt gleich
auf jeden fall möchte ich sagen also
wenn man sich überlegt ich glaube dass
seine attitude nicht nur bei sportlern
gut ankommt denn wenn ich mir überlege
wer soll das land regieren dann doch
lieber jemand der fit ist und dadurch
auch geistig auf der höhe ist scholz
könnte sich quasi auch als
wahlkampfspruch geben für ein gesundes
deutschland also alles andere kann bei
mir so stehen bleiben genau wie bei dir
ihren auf platz 2 sehe ich hier das wäre
ja eigentlich was du vor schoss dann
aber eine koalition mit ein bisschen
vertauschten personal also eine rote
ampel mit einem kandidaten aus münchen
dann als ja aber ich habe nein ich hab
ein paar geheiratet das muss möglich
sein ok also ich möchte noch sagen warum
linda bei mir auf zwei ist er ist der
ewige posterboy und ich fand dass der
gestern aber gezeigt hat und auch schon
immer zeigt dass
klugheit automatisch schön macht der
sieht einfach immer gut aus weil er so
viel weiß er hat extrem gutes
analytisches wissen faktenwissen nicht
nur bei wirtschaftsfragen deshalb ist er
bei mir auf platz zwei und auf 3 markus
söder der wirkt einfach neben scholz am
staatsmännischen und dass lukas macht
schon sagst du gültig auch für frauen
ich hoffe
gestern wurde ja auch christian linder
bei uns in der sendung zum attraktivsten
politiker gekürt von unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern mit ihm
wollen die meisten frauen ins bett
wirklich ja also ich möchte nicht mit
ihm ins bett um das immer ganz andere
das sollte doch gar nicht dafür aber
gut dass wir das hier mal klar gestellt
haben du hast das hotel natürlich
gestern auch ein bisschen unter anderem
unter einem anderen augenwinkel
betrachtet und zwar stylish outfit
technisch fertig da am meisten überzeugt
ja wahlkabinen und umkleidekabine liegen
tatsächlich gar nicht so weit
auseinander politiker in deutschland
tragen ja gerne uniformen also merkel
zum beispiel ohne blazer wäre überhaupt
nicht denkbar in amerika ist das
teilweise anders wer uns kamelle harris
louis gilt ja als sie den wahlkampf sieg
verkündet hat da war sie im jogginganzug
unterwegs und auch obama trug mal flip
flops und
da hätten jetzt gestern die frauen in
der runde punkten können das haben sie
aber leider nicht getan annalena
baerbock die trägt ja auch manchmal
blümchen kleider oder eine lederjacke
aber gestern sah sie aus wie alle
anderen trug einen blauen anzug bloß
nichts falsch machen bloß nicht anecken
und das finde ich schade also eine blaue
stylische blaue pumps auch dazu ja was
also langweilig aussehen her authentisch
gewesen wenn sie was anderes angezogen
ja wirklich
und dann muss ich sagen alice weidl ist
ein grund keine perlenketten mehr zu
tragen also selten wurde ja so ein
schönes schmuckstück durch unschöne
worte herabgewürdigt und das passt auch
gar nicht zu ihr weil sie gibt sich ja
immer so volksnah und perlenketten sind
eigentlich ein zeichen für reichtum muss
ich sagen und das passt auch dazu nichts
an ihr passt ihre aussagen passen nicht
sie hat sich als china fan geoutet dann
hat sie plötzlich über den reaktor
gesprochen
kein mensch wusste was sie damit meinte
wie das eigentlich funktionieren soll
also das waren sogar diskussion ich
hätte da lieber über ganz andere sachen
das gut ich dachte im ersten moment da
sitzen stewardess oder eine pilotin auch
mit jahren ein stilistischer artige
frisur ja also niemand könnte strenger
wirken als absoluter beton also wir
fassen noch mal zusammen christian
endler hat nicht nach ganz oben
geschafft jan du hast keine goldmedaille
vergeben
und ja wir wollen und dein fazit am ende
würdest du sagen tatsächlich olaf scholz
ist der coolste und
klaus
die ganze zeit still gefühl wenn ich die
ausstellung anschauen und nicht weil ich
was gegen die damals das ist ganz
wichtig dass man das sieht ich glaube
wenn man die drei sieht dann denkt man
es geht alles so weiter wie bisher
lindner stets dafür was neues ist aber
auch schon ewig im geschäft und keine
ahnung was die beiden ja sowieso ich
glaube schon dass da so ein bisschen so
was mit rein muss in einem kohle in eine
zukunfts koalition damit man das gefühl
hat es ist auch es sind nicht nur die
gleichen alten gesichter weil es ein
junges gesicht ein tolles gesicht mit
dem alle alles mögliche machen haben
gelernt wie gelernt habe aber es muss
schon da irgendwie irgendwie so ein
bisschen was neues ein das verleiht dann
auch den andern mehr ich will nicht
sagen klemmen aber mehr zukunft das ist
schon auch eine aufstellung der
vergangenheit muss man sagen mir wäre es
dann schon bei aller liebe lieber wenn
sich die grünen da eine rolle für sachen
und so kommt ja auch ich glaube sogar
dass hören wir auch aus grünen kreisen
dass sie im grunde beide koalitionen
schon bauen aus ihrer sicht also jamaika
und die ampel die ist also sozusagen
nicht wegzudenken er wird es auch machen
er darf nicht mit spielen also ist es ja
vielleicht das
oder das und das ist ja eigentlich für
die nächsten stunden sind nur ein paar
stunden bis zur wahl in wahrheit ne das
ist ja die frage wollen wir das
oder wollen wir das aber du kannst doch
nicht ernsthaft wollen dass
ich
meine
ok also das ist übrigens die
linke bisher weiter hieraus bürger
puppenkiste spielen wir machen derweil
schon auf weiter vielen dank
[Musik]